at the White House last night the
president honored America's oldest Ally
at the first state dinner of his term
the guest of honor was French president
Emmanuel macron and the guest list
included lots of big names people you
know the official state visit included
plenty of business talk too including
talk about the war in Ukraine and Global
inflation Zhang is at the White House
with more on that part of the story
weisha good morning to you it's quite a
night at the White House last night good
morning to you good morning to everybody
it was Glitz and glamor all the way it
took nearly two years for the Biden
Administration to host the state dinner
because the pandemic put it on pause but
the party was back and of course France
is known for its food and fashion both
were on full display so was friendship
as presidents Biden and macron tried to
reassure the world that their bond is
stronger than ever
a warm embrace kicked off the first
state dinner in three years the ending
to a day devoted to diplomacy during a
press conference presidents Biden and
macron voice support for Ukraine and
condemned Vladimir Putin although the
leaders don't agree on how to deal with
him mccrone has maintained communication
with Putin Mr Biden has closed it off
but with just the slightest of wiggle
room I'm prepared to speak with Mr Putin
if in fact there is an interest in him
society and he's looking for a way to
end the war he hasn't done that yet the
Crone has also criticized the inflation
reduction act one of the president's
signature accomplishments because it
includes subsidies for u.s-made electric
vehicles President Biden stood by his
policy the United States makes no
apology
and I make no apology since I wrote it
for the legislation you're talking about
the president went on to say there could
be tweaks to the measure to include
European countries a sign that the two
heads of state were projecting Unity we
want to succeed together not one against
the other like many world leaders before
them they hit the red carpet together to
kick off the evening festivities first
lady Dr Jill Biden dazzled in a custom
Oscar de la Renta gown her French
counterpart Bridget macron stunned in an
ivory Louis Vuitton President Biden said
it was fitting that France was the guest
of honor at his first state dinner
France was our first Ally first country
to fly the American flag after a
Revolution France has been our first
friend nearly 350 guests filled a glass
Pavilion on the south lawn
including Late Show host Stephen Colbert
actress Julia Louis-Dreyfus and French
shoe designer Christian Louboutin
along with a decadent meal guests were
treated to a performance by Grammy
award-winning musician John Batiste
we're going to forge together Viva La
France and God bless America
today Emmanuel macron heads to New
Orleans to the French Quarter for a tour
he will also be talking about climate
change and of course enjoying an evening
of jazz the last time a French president
visited that city was back in 1976. Vlad
I guess our invites got lost in the mail
uh we just hang at the White House for
us thank you very much